[Music]
you're what kind of okay a ceremony
commit to know better care to brothers
and sisters in dear friends welcome to
Salam corner and I welcome new to Salaam
corner as well so salaam corner Salam
means peace ok said I'm put on east
corner okay so we're trying to get rid
of the evil of arguments unnecessary
confrontations all that kind of stuff
and which one have nice civilized
discussions fruitful discussion that we
can learn from one another yes so if I'm
not mistaken
is there another person that looks like
you that comes here he has the things on
the floor is that you originally I came
here and I had this kind of information
as you yeah on the floor yes and then as
time has progressed over the years I
they're not brought chairs and so and
they could sit down and talk basically
the same thing that you're doing here
okay what should he I'm mister I see
three threesome mister I see three
because I see three represents black
yeah and under the British system the
British state yeah okay what about me
where do I want my I want to be
something is wrong my c7 uh no no your
official classification is I see six
okay so that covers Jewish Muslim
Buddhist British from Turkey Oh Cody
from Turkey right oh I'm special I've
got special oh yeah my my ICC see me
give you let me just give you some
information about it well they're very
interesting so officially yes you said
you are Kurdish from Turkey nuts
so look Kurdish people are okay
Rd Kurdish yes and they are put
classified with
Arabs and the mixed-race yes but what's
interesting here is that Turkish people
look there's three types of Turkish so
the British state recognizes Turkish
people as white and Kurdish people as
Muslim or Arab so I don't know what
could you tell me why you think the
British would separate the Turkish from
the that's my interest from the Kurdish
I have my I have some ideas do you think
they are I don't know if you can some
part of Turkey to the European side or
maybe that they come from the Roman the
Byzantine
there's definitely some history
definitely history that I don't know and
it's very hard to get that extract that
information from the British State
because you've got to do a a Freedom of
Information request and when you do a
Freedom of Information request you've
got to know how to ask the right
question otherwise they'll say that we
don't know what you're talking about
right so what what you assume I I would
agree with you that it is got goes way
back in history I suspect by speaking to
many Turkish and Kurdish people over the
years it appears that the Kurdish people
have something to do with Saladin yes
yeah and Saladin what was fighting
against the Crusaders or something like
that
so it could be why yeah that's right so
I suspect that the Kurdish people are
seen as the enemy of the early Christian
Crusaders so they they they they won't
they'll never classify you as white okay
they see that you you know that that's
why I suspect I don't know okay but the
Turkish people they don't know I can ask
you what is your purpose like what would
you do what superb is that coming to the
pot yes chemical isn't it so people get
concepts obviously people to understand
that's very interesting
yeah why did you do this what's the
purpose tell us a bit more right so the
reason I come to the park or my position
here in the park is I speak about
fundamentally identity politics
identity politics as far as I understand
covers all subjects because if you say
you're a Muslim you have to identify as
a Muslim here if you say you're a
Christian you have to identify as a
Christian but you cannot tell visually
the different wiener a Muslim and a
Christian or a real Muslim and the fake
Muslim so its internal exactly because
just add on that each other yeah in
Islam there were people who were known
as a monastic the hypocrites sorry a
monastic were nasty yeah so they were
known as the hypocrites they would claim
on their tongue their Muslim but in
their heart they were disbelievers right
so we can't know who is what right right
so therefore you have an identity issue
and the next level would be who can
identify a real Muslim from a fake
Muslim but some people are right some
people would say I'll only Allah can
tell the difference between a room was
them in a fake Muslim whilst others
would say no the normal people should be
able to see by their fruits or their
works whether this Muslim is a good
Muslim or bad was think or Christian or
Jew is a real jewel or not well I can't
breathe coffee
yes are you Greek right so if he says
he's Greek
right no person no person can be Greek
and Muslim at the same time because okay
look see Greek it's three ha white race
yeah and Greeks are riparian there is
white sea by British Standard British
Steiner okay look at the terms in their
dog see by the Kurds gods Clare's can
see the Kurdish are put with the Arabs
here look on the race is done are you
more
mimimi
I'm other race yes it means I'm special
it's two types of Irish there's the
woodwork Irish and white traveller of
Irish heritage no and Turkey are not the
same okay yes also you're involved in
identity identity politics yes right way
out of everything that way right because
identity politics is the ultimate
subject because as we said discussed
earlier how do you differentiate between
a true Muslim and a fake was him some
would say only Allah can tell children
yeah but there are others who say that
Europe your your fellow members should
also tell you reminded me of something
okay Islam said that's before for some
people say ah don't judge me don't judge
me when I'm sitting here yeah what I've
said
used to judge by revelation the
revelation is stopped now we judge while
was apparent oh hey that hey that very
serious is very serious
Kurdish and Syrian you know because
because to judge by what's apparent is
they're gonna judge you by your actions
correct yes and what you're doing yes
and then this please real to the
question I want you to ask how you hold
the camera which moves on to the next
question but I understand that there is
a Muslim motion move and Muslims elegant
Muslim Muslim leader Muslims look look a
mock min but I had its most Shin I know
I know Muslim and movement the movement
is the one that's reach the pinnacle
relief yeah and there's Muslim because
Allah says in the Quran though mostly
man in the Muslim world the believing
men and the believing were so a lot of
the fishes between the Muslim and the
believing so he's made it seems to show
an Arab so he said don't say that you're
a believer you're a Muslim so meaning
you've submitted but you haven't really
encompassed what belief means yeah right
so so
in your opinion would the move mean move
mean be I would would you be able to see
the actions that a movement is a genuine
Muslim okay by their actions just
quickly what is that cross Samara
I was it is essential to come we make a
bit children yeah I would say from the
outer parent actually you might see
someone just enough you have people come
here just in a certain why holy looking
but internally we don't know so from
their parent yes you can see the actions
that we see we observe so for example
the prophet said to us you cannot say
that you know somebody I think the
processor I remember you do not know
somebody until you've done business with
them
you've traveled with them and you've
lived with them so you can't come and
say you know anybody on to you is try
and lift well and that's so true because
sometimes you think that you know I is
my friend you get into business well
he's somebody else you travel with him
you live with him guys you know keeps
picking his nose oh I don't know what
kind of stuff yet
or you live with him so this is how you
know a person okay so we can't judge but
internally we don't know okay so which
side would you be on would you be on the
side that says nobody can judge only
Allah knows how the real Muslim or not
slow down let me ask the question and
they've been here so there's two sides I
understand one side is that no only
Allah knows the true Muslim and the fake
Muslim leave that to Allah no man can
know the other side is that
[Music]
Muslim brothers and sisters can tell who
are members of their family and and
their and their judgment of the Muslim
or machine will be in harmony with Allah
they you know but because they're
following Allah they will have the same
insight and vision of Allah to degree
and so they were to tell whether
somebody is true or false so which side
are you on
okay what we say is a forum we say
nobody can declare anyone at this
believer innovator evil doer yeah unless
there is apparent characteristics so if
somebody stumps on a Quran we would say
the action of that is disbelief however
did he know that Stefan on the Quran
could render him is he sane so they stop
the render but then you have certain
groups that will come and deem anyone a
disbeliever innovator and this is
ignorant this absolutely whose because
this is masters of the spawners so you
cannot come and say however so yeah so
the thing is when it comes to that it's
very severe because who is a Muslim and
not God knows really but there's certain
actions that we can see and say hold on
a second this man is saying oh I bow
down to Jesus
no Muslim simple is that you know Muslim
because you're doing something that is
fundamentally against the teachers of is
done so that renders your belief right
but because of by that person's actions
you can then make a decision and the
community can then make them community
of Islam can then make a judgment on
that person yes right okay the action
they do right and you follow that side
yes okay I can say okay he is a Muslim I
call comedy's a disbeliever
but his action that he's doing and
confirmed that to me if he says I
believe Jesus is also a part of good
you're not missing anymore right but
stimuli you just uttered
Lorraine yeah we just run you just well
fundamentally fits in to whether
identity it once again Islamic community
from what you're saying can identify a
true by their actions or by their
declaration yes so I understand your
position yeah so that was my question
so you're trying to raise awareness like
are you happy with this is the other
problem with its ways it that you like
right okay so we move on to a next a
higher level now where my raising
awareness of this information I am
making people aware of the British state
opinion not even Indian individuals if
you speak to individuals that say oh
that's racist or that's not raised all
kinds of confusion which they see us
yeah right so so I I was away or
individual conversation about race and
racism and then I deal with what the
power power is a state they have the
power to put you in prison and take you
out or you fight against your nation so
the only interest I have when it comes
to talking about identity and race and
ethnicity is what is the state position
what is the belief of the state and then
what is the religion so just so how I
see this just like you Muslims will have
the Quran
this is this is the British ground here
yeah that's how serious this is their
operate bite yeah I've been doing for
years that's right so this is the
British state faith religion well here's
a challenge you see it's taken me many
years to get this much information Wow
and I've had to do do it by Freedom of
Information request yes
so a bit like prayer that's like sending
a letter to God
yes so like prayer you have to be very
clear when you're communicating with the
power so over the years as I've tried to
understand this Quran the British Quran
I send information requests but if you
ask if you send an information request
to the state and you make a mistake in
the way your question is really yes or
into what the words that you choose
there you won't get your prayers
answered no in other words you won't get
a response
you aren't understood here they will not
give you more information so in order to
be a notice to judge for how to hold
hold in order to make a judgment on this
whether the British state is right or
wrong
I would have to know how they are using
their Quran or their holy book you know
so I know exists there it is but you
know I can't call them racist or dispute
or unjust because I would have to get
certain information about how it's being
used to in order to make a judgment and
whether I believe it's good or it's bad
so what's your decision it's a good or
bad I can't say because I'm Constance
constantly trying to gather okay or
information okay
forget the British government you're
making you're asking them players
they're not answering crater gods
straight okay dan I respond to the
caller that calls upon me and he doesn't
say Muslim he says anyone that calls
upon me I respond to them okay I invite
you to his thumb taking Shahada now we
can continue at some other time sure
yeah I think that's been quite oh okay
what were you yeah I see this'll always
this are you were undercover Christian
be honest okay yeah my my my personal
ideology is I am national racialist not
a National Socialist national racialist
and what does that mean
that means I believe that a nation
conserves a race and they're like
conservatives so that conservative party
is supposed to be conserving something
so what are they conserving okay right
so national racially the means and they
should conserve the race and a race
conserves a nation and then ethnicities
come under race yeah brilliant that's
actually very informative obviously said
hope you guys have learned
is that nuts it goes okay so the
question is you want to come at us
okay was it was it okay we're gonna
engage the discussion thank you for
watching brother sisters that was gonna
have a discussion now asking some
information about what this means okay
what is this paranormal activity